Hopefully now the way that we modified this equation for our line earlier makes
a little bit more sense. Remember that we had y minus t equals m times x minus
s. But what does this really mean? Let's think back to what we called different
parts of our line, or different characteristics of our line, when we created
this equation. Well, this t was our y coordinate of the point that we knew. So
this left hand side of the equation really says y minus the y coordinate and on
the right side, m was our slope and s was our x coordinate. So we've just
derived another way to work out the equation of the line. That's pretty
impressive. This is really incredible that you guys did this yourself. Now, any
time that we know the coordinates of a point on a line s and t, or the x
coordinate and the y coordinate. And we know the slope of the line, we can
automatically write that line's equation. This is a super, super powerful tool.
However, I'm lazy, and writing it out this way is really time consuming. But
writing it in the original way doesn't really show us what s and t actually
stand for. It's a little bit Less clear what the meaning of these letters is.
Let's see what we can do about this. Instead of calling our point here s, t I
think we should call it x1, y1. That way whenever we use these terms in the
equation we know what kind of values they are. We know whatever is in the place
of x1 is going to be an x coordinate and whatever is in the place of y1 is going
to be a y coordinate. So that updates this equation. Remember that y and x here
are general variables, but x1 and y1 will be the fixed values that we pick based
on a concrete point that we know. These values will vary. As we move up and down
the line. These values will stay fixed.